this is a year and a half grave since
she was like eight weeks old
what's up what's the best trick you've
ever taught peaches or any dog oh please
is gonna do anything oh really yeah
what's his best trick her best trick me
to do what she want whatever that might
be how about you guys what it's like
have you ever had any tricks or fur fur
pets or anything like that oh gosh you
know I've never I can have to admit I
have not spent a lot of time teaching
tricks to to my dogs but you know there
obviously there's Wade we'd rather say
behavior how do you teach attraction
attraction attraction attention she's
really not wanting to be right yeah I
know she's like yes out she's like
where's one there's one Tory yeah well
how important do you feel like it is to
have a dog as a child or as as a person
well it's I'm just thinking enriches
your life it's it's the first having a
dog when you're a kid is the first
experience you have of responsibility
for another being you know sure like
it's close to come - yeah I guess it's a
little bit like playing with dolls as a
kid only this one's alive and you have
to take care of it even though your
parents always wind up taking care of
their at least you know the idea starts
to form in your head I mean this movie
deals with pretty deep sort of subject
matters like mortality and death via dog
how important do you feel like it is to
have that script message in this well
yeah it's a way of teaching kids real
life straight out a little buffer there
and dogs are always there for you
restage life no matter what it is
without judgment and they you definitely
have empathy darts know how to radiate
empathy yeah for some reason you know
they could they can really read your
emotions have you both ever had to have
that discussion about you know the loss
of a pet or anything like that and how
do you deal with that well yes with my
own son you know yes when when my not my
current dog was alive and well and lots
of spirit even though he's 11 sure he's
a kind of a big boy
but um ya know it was it was a talking
to my son who was wasn't it he was so I
see he was fifteen maybe hey I wasn't a
small child but you know it was it was
painful I mean it was a painful
experience and we all like talked about
it we share it's like stories about some
of our favorite stories about Momo was
the dog's name and just to kind of like
kind of grieve together and and you know
and we had us had ashes and actually had
I just recently just like had the ashes
spread and like one of his favorite
hikes that's so lovely yeah yeah because
I was I'm gonna be moving soon and I I
thought well I'm gonna just let him
skill free now so yeah there's all kinds
of lessons that of all stages of life
and in anyone's life and have been your
dog's life it's a great like this data
set a way to teach a child about these
the big issues in life